here's how it's gonna work Joel and I
have identical grocery items and bag
options we have 40 seconds to bag
everything as quickly and carefully as
possible once time is up grace will
judge our bagging abilities and declare
a winner do you get it can you repeat
the rules but wait we need a prize this
could be for the catch surprised if Joel
wins all the men in the audience gets my
book okay those four dudes are excited
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all the women will get the book
[Applause]
all right here we go okay what go go go
thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
done
[Applause]
oh my god you're so invited for game
night I love your spirit outside so
strong all right okay boy judge we're
doing point Kelly and Joel both get a
point cuz they used brown paper bags but
we should have used reusable right you
want a guy you would got more points for
me why did it okay getting more look
this is bigger this is why you I'm not
gonna get as much in here I'm just
saying I'm on your side whatever yeah I
see the mistake but okay okay Kelly gets
two points for the eggs on top Joel gets
two points for the bread on chips okay
so I'm minus 1.8 they're heavy and
frozen one extra point for Joel oh yeah
teachers either these are these are
crushable finally I was just worried
about saving the Oreos five points for
Kelly for even distribution so it's okay
to crush things open - no - one point
for Joel because of the eggs were not
the bread and the chips were on top of
yeah you should've been in the middle
cushion okay
okay - a point for Kelly for these on
the bottom there on the side only one
point - the Orioles are good on the
bottom the Oreos were in the bottom
everything heavy is on the bottom I'm
gonna my win a final edition of five
points for jewel because cuz he put all
the cold stuff together and even
distribution now eight to eight so we
don't so I'm going with that if
everybody wins and everybody
just whoever wants it just grab one of
the guitars hanging on the wall just
grab go ahead just have that whatever
you like that's fine
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going